is
it's because
hello everyone
uh hello everyone i am siddharth and i
am going to sort of give an overview
about perfect sampling and it's more
like an invitation
uh it's an area which is kind of
classical but has only recently seen
revived interest
so
i thought i'll start off with a concrete
problem and then
give some further directions and to give
you a flavor of what this is about so
let's take one very concrete problem
which we possibly all have encountered
in some form
we are given a graph
on n vertices and
of max degree delta and we are given a
set of colors k
we want to sample uniformly from the set
of all proper colorings of this column
so basically a coloring in which two
matrix
and
the thing is that i want to emphasize
the word exactly i want to sample
exactly according to the distribution
path
and of course we know this is an lp hard
problem to even determine whether this
set script c is empty or not which is
the set of all proper colorings so we
typically work in a regime where we know
that things are easy like k is greater
than delta plus 1 so we know 3d coloring
will work and and naive except project
sampling will not work because it would
take too long
and our goal is to find the minimum
value of c assuming that k is more than
sometimes delta
uh
to find the minimum value of c such that
we can design efficient sampling
algorithms from this
for this problem
uh so i'm going to sort of rush through
the setup because i'm sure most of you
are comfortable with it uh so the change
sort of the method of choice here is to
use this markov chain called global
dynamics which is very popular and it's
a very simple thing i'm sure all of you
know it but just to recall it the way it
works is the following it takes a
coloring guide and chooses a random
vertex
and then
it sort of takes a random color which is
a legal color at me so any color which
is outside the set of block colors
denoted by chi and v so let's say it
chooses the color yellow
and it just assigns this randomly chosen
color to the vertex v and that's how
this update works as simple as things
can get and of course uh typically the
way this chain gets used is in the
setting of approximate sampling where
one
asks for a weaker demand that is we
don't sample exactly according to five
but close enough to buy in some total
variation distance or some other
and uh the way it works is you start
with the coloring at zero and you keep
on applying this change repeatedly for a
fixed amount of time and in the end you
show by some method that
this distribution at the end x t will be
pretty close to pi
and
one thing to note here is that
if you want the distance to come within
epsilon p usually scales as log one over
epsilon and
the thing is this is not quite enough
for us because we want epsilon to be
zero so this won't give you a perfect
example right or it will make the
algorithm infeasible
so
one can ask okay why do we need to
exactly sample if uh if we can go away
with perfect sampling
uh well firstly i find this to be a very
elegant and interesting question right
it's kind of
the methods we'll see here are some of
the prettiest i have seen in
whatever you can call the probabilistic
toolbox
and uh it also helps you design faster
counting schemes
in in some cases
and
the other reason which is sort of more
uh practically motivated is that it
provides it provides your stopping time
criteria so if you have some sampling
task for which you have designed a
markov chain you usually just run it for
some time and hope that the sample you
get is close enough to your distribution
if you don't have mixing time guarantees
because there is no stopping criteria
that a markov chain usually comes with
but these algorithms come with a
stopping time criteria so you might not
be able to say how
fast the algorithm will terminate but
the sample quality is never suspect so
that is an advantage
uh anyways let me just give a comparison
of approximate and exact sampling to
tell you how well the two things match
or how far apart they are whichever way
you look at it so of course there is a
classical result of jerome who showed
that this global dynamics mixes fast
when the number of colors is more than
two times delta
and then googly and dyer sort of
reproved it using the framework of path
coupling and there are lots of results
which i'm skipping of course there's a
huge body of work but vigorous in 2000
had this breakthrough
where he showed that related dynamics
called flip dynamics mixes at eleven by
six delta
and
it was improved further
very recently
but on the side of
exact sampling of perfect sampling not
too much was known the seminal result
was of cuba who came up with a very nice
technology to even be able to perfectly
sample but you can see that the number
of colors required are quadratic in
delta so there was a huge gap between
the two
regimes
and then there was a
big interlude and in 2019 feng and yen
were able to improve this
bound by some linear factor in delta for
very restricted families of graphs so
the number of colors should not be more
than log log and that was their
setting
and
then in a remarkable breakthrough new
sinclair and shivastava were able to
give a deterministic approximate counter
which matches almost jerome's region but
the drawback was it was efficient only
when delta was constant when you have
four constant degree cross and in a work
which scientist is my colleague at pi
pass you are actually able to bring that
quadratic bound down to a linear bound
three times delta for general graphs
so
and
in fact this has been improved even
further by another result of jane shaw
and sony which where this bound is
morally now eight by three delta
and actually yeah now that i think of it
this uses this technique of
preconditioning which we sort of heard
about in a couple of talks
before this one
and i sort of now want to in the
remaining five minutes i want to give
you a very quick flavor of what goes on
in this exact sampling and why is it so
much more difficult than approximate
sampling as if approximate sampling
weren't difficult enough
so
firstly it's a fascinating question if i
give you a markov chain p with a
stationary distribution pi
can you do something using this markov
chain to get samples which are exactly
distributed from pi
and there's a breakthrough work of prop
and wilson in 1996 but the ideas sort of
date back all the ways to 60s to the
1960s called coupling from the past and
if you haven't seen this i highly
encourage you to give it a look it is
i'm sure it will put a smile on your
face it is pretty it is pretty pretty
so
so the idea here is very simple
it says that okay let's sort of jointly
evolve a markov chain
from t equal to minus infinity to 0 and
you can see the time indexes are now
negative so that's why that word past is
there and so you are running a markov
chain from each state i will sort of get
to it
uh in a little more detail on the next
slide but bear with me so p if that
joint evolution rule is reasonable you
expect that by the time t equal to 0 all
the chains would have coalesced to a
unique state omega star and you just
output omega star that's the algorithm
of course now
the point is
omega star is distributed exactly
according to the distribution file that
is the claim they prove and the other
thing is how do you run this
algorithmically because you can't run it
for so many steps
that doesn't make sense
so
let's take an example of what they are
trying to say or rather let's try to
understand better what they are trying
to say so they are generating these
random updates these random views
uh such that
each ui
if you look at marginally if you look at
any state like there i have highlighted
the state omega to
the transition omega prime it looks like
the markov chain p is being followed
that is the first requirement you need
to satisfy and
then basically you want to find the
first index
uh like let's say minus t in this case
says that this composed function is a
constant
and it should be clear that this is
enough because if if i know the image of
u minus t composed all the way to u
minus 1 is a constant that is omega star
it doesn't matter what has happened
previously in time it's as if i found a
shortcut to run all the minus infinity
to zero steps
so this is the basic idea like
uh let me sort of in the interest of
time take a very quick example of how
this would have worked so in the u so
let's take our favorite example which is
a random walk on the line with the
probability transition probabilities
half each side
and a looping probability of half at the
end
so then the cftp would look something
like this these random updates
are described by
a number between 0 and 1 generated
randomly and if it is more than half you
sort of take a step upwards and if it is
less than half you take a step backwards
and this is a joint update for all these
states
uh in our state space so our state space
is are the states of the chain
and you keep on evolving this
this
random updates you compose them until
they become a constant function so that
is what the cftp algorithm will look
like of course uh
i i mean
it's very easy to generate a random
sample from this distribution but i
wanted to sort of yeah okay i have one
minute that's all i need i wanted to
sort of say what happens for the case of
paladins why is it so much more
difficult so here is one natural way to
implement our global dynamics in this
setting of cfpt
uh you
you take these random updates to be
given by
a random permutation sigma minus one
sigma minus these are all random
permutations and a vertex where you want
to apply the update okay and then how is
this update interpreted so you take a
coloring pie
and add the vertex v
you choose the first available color
according to sigma so like if your sigma
i happens to be this permutation of
colors and your vertex v i is v
then you can see that
the color red is sort of blocked for me
but it's occupied by its navel but the
color yellow is free and
that is how we will implement this
update uh
this is basically taking the global
dynamics and lifting it to the setting
of cfd
the problem here
which makes this challenge sort of very
interesting is that
firstly we need to understand how long
in time will i have to go before this
image becomes a constant function and
the second
problem is even if this were true that
is you know in polynomial time i can
ensure that this happens how do i keep
track of evolving so many chains they
are going to be exponentially many
chains in the case of graph columns so
these are the kind of challenges i i
mean one has to deal with in this
setting and i'll now sort of skip all
this because i don't
i have any time for this but
let's leave this up and i just want to
sort of uh
leave you with a few broad questions
firstly can we prove a jbv like this
jerome william and vazirani have these
classical results about various notions
of sampling and counting
but can we do something about relating
approximate sampling with perfect
sampling
uh and
if not in generality at least for
restricted problems like spin systems
and more importantly i want to
understand does it have benefits to
other areas
like
where you know there might be a lot of
error or you might have to boost up
approximate sampling and lose runtime
because of that boost maybe at a similar
run time you can actually get away if
you use an exact sampling framework
thank you
[Applause]
questions
thanks